grandmaster dingler in will join us and
there he is
welcome welcome welcome
nice to have you on the show how are you
oh good that's good
in barcelona
you're in barcelona
i see uh
tell us your thoughts what what what do
you think about what's going on with
magnus and
your new elevated position mr
dingler
well this is my eighth interview
yeah
uh three
uh
in china uh no three all sides of china
is five in china
ah well we wanted to be the last
uh i think so
and what have you been saying to the
people
oh well
yeah i didn't expect his decisions
but it's understandable
since
uh it's clear he
he makes some motivations to defend
another titles
yeah also the crown had
gave him maybe too much pressure and the
responsibilities had to handle with
so he preferred to enjoy playing chess
other than suffering
nicely put
and do you feel
that
you will be suffering having to play a
million dollar world championship match
uh since it's my first time to fight for
the world championship
so
there's a lot of fresh air i can breathe
and yes the everything new
and
still there are a long time
to go
um for the
world championship
thing
first of all congratulations what are
the first steps right now you're in this
position uh the match maybe is a year
away from now how are you going to put
together your preparation plan what is
next what is the next step for dingley
red
[Music]
maybe the
the special preparation will come just
before the tournament i i think i guess
the best way for me is just
keep it normal
and as usual
and
do what i do
[Music]
uh
in europe
so
just before the tournament i will do
some special
preparation just according to the
specific player and for the openings but
before that i think the most important
thing is to improve your general strings
are you going to put together a team of
seconds right now do you have any names
in mind and if you don't want to answer
that question you feel like it's
revealing too much don't worry about it
yes i have
one or two names
yeah
yeah and he's
close to me
but i don't think it's the most
important thing
what is the feeling like in china
are they proud
that
you will be competing for the world
championship you will be the first
chinese man
to compete in the open championship you
have already many world champions
in the ladies game
you'll be the first male uh what is the
feeling like in china
yeah we have many women world
championship
and also many uh teams championship but
we don't have any um male challengers
for the world crown so
yes
they are very excited about the
possibilities
and i think when i get back to china
they will
talk to me more seriously and
they will try to help me
absolutely very very exciting
times uh miro any questions for our
finalists yeah well yeah i had a lot but
somehow i don't don't even know what to
say yeah uh it is a controversial one
because of course like magnus stepping
away made you to play the match but uh
would you agree that it's a little bit
sad for let's say for a chess world that
the champion and you know number one
rated player that he kind of steps away
from the magic
yes since
i also understand his decisions
you know sometimes uh
early player is not so
um
object of of mystic about the
maybe world championship and
even the future
of chess
like this
maybe
sometimes
uh
also feel that
uh
difficult to find the right words uh
ding we want to thank you so very much
for taking time out of your day and
joining us
and sharing your thoughts but it's a
dream come true for you
so we're going to wish you a lot of
success yeah as a
world championship match
finalist thank you thank you very much
thank you very much
and there you have it miro